qu'on a subi en fait de plein fouet ça
rejoint complètement votre commission
aujourd'hui c'est que en fait toute la
stratégie mise en place par mes
prédécesseurs en 2011 et 2013 et à la
suite de la crise H1 on avait beaucoup
hurlé sur les stocks trop importants la
plupart des rapports avec la même pointé
du doigt la gabegie financière etc donc
mes prédécesseurs avaient pris des
décisions de faire des stocks tournants
c'est remis dans le circuit
régulièrement pour éviter justement les
péremptions ce que ce que d'un point de
vue logistique santé publique France
avait du mal à mettre en oeuvre et des
stocks tampons c'est quoi un stock
tampon c'est-à-dire on sait à l'époque
les gouvernements qui avaient pris ces
décisions en 2011 et 2013 elle est dit
plutôt que d'avoir des stocks de
milliards de produits de santé qu'on ne
sait pas gérer parce que ça ça
représente des entrepôts de type Amazon
c'était de la logistique on va faire des
stocks pour un mois en attendant les
commandes et donc on se met en état
d'attendre des commandes sauf que ce que
personne n'avait anticipé à l'époque je
pense c'est que même s'il y avait des
productions importantes dans différents
pays quand j'étais importante
même s'il y avait plusieurs sites de
production
de masques ou de documents de protection
en Europe en fait personne n'avait
réalisé que les matières premières qui
servent à fabriquer des masques était
toute fabriquées à One et dans la région
de Roubaï donc au moment où on a
commandé des masses puisque moi j'ai
lancé mes premières commandes le 24
janvier one venait d'être fermé par des
chinois et donc en fait ils n'ont pas
exporté les matières premières et ça je
crois que personne n'avait tiré le fil
jusqu'au bout et c'est exactement ce
qu'on a avec les pénuries de médicament
principe actif délocalisé dans une usine
en Chine et le monde entier en paie le
prix en fait pour le Mas était pareil
sauf que personne n'était au courant et
donc personne n'avait anticipé des
besoins de stock bien supérieurs par
ailleurs et je le regrette parce que
personne n'a vraiment tirer le fil
jusqu'au bout de ce qu'il aurait fallu
comme stock de masse pour tenir un
manque contrairement à ce qu'on dit ça
n'est pas un milliards mais c'est 4
milliards parce que la consommation
était d'un milliard par semaine pourquoi
ça n'avait pas été envisagé parce qu'il
n'y a jamais eu jamais aucune
recommandation au monde jusqu'à ce que
l'OMS change sa recommandation en juin
2000 20 de port du masque en population
générale donc de toute façon tous les
calculs avaient été fait pour stocker
des masques pour les soignants et les
malades et ça ça n'avait jamais
évidemment abouti un stock d'un milliard
donc en réalité tous les problèmes ont
été mélangés je ne reviendrai pas sur la
complexité de cette crise mais elle est
liée à deux fêtes premièrement que
jamais personne n'avait envisagé qu'il
fallait des masques en population
générale et que ça n'a été créé dans
aucune recommandation au monde j'ai fait
toute la littérature sur le sujet pour
l'accord de justice de la République
donc je peux vous dire que je mets au
défi qui que ce soit de trouver une
recommandation différente et
deuxièmement
personne n'avait envisagé que la
totalité des matières premières pour les
produits de protection étaient faites
dans la région de Dubaï qui allait être
fermée parce que c'était l'épicentre
d'une épidémie c'est-à-dire comme
malchance vous voyez si cette matière
première avait été fabriquée en
Thaïlande aux États-Unis nous n'aurions
pas eu cette même de commando alors
beaucoup de choses qui se sont
concentrées à ce moment-là mais en fait
sa pointe exactement la difficulté que
nous subissons aujourd'hui avec les
médicaments et la nécessité d'une
souveraineté et c'est là où j'en reviens
au fait que
malheureusement nous avons une mémoire
courte tous parce que pour les masques
comme pour les pénuries de médicaments
on a vu qu'on avait relancé la
production de masques en France pendant
la crise covid et puis on a vu
progressivement que les prix de
production étant cher et bien
progressivement les hôpitaux ont arrêté
d'acheter les producteurs français ils
ont fait faillite et on est reparti sur
des masques fabriqués je ne sais où donc
c'est c'est là où je
je pense qu'il y a il y a quand même
dans les solutions quand même la prise
en compte dans les critères d'achat
notamment de nos établissements publics
des prises en compte de critères de
souveraineté ça je crois un
impérativement qu'on ne peut pas
toujours avoir le prix comme critère
principal de choix d'un prestataire pour
les hôpitaux bon après ça coûte cher et
évidemment ça nécessite peut-être des
moyens financiers supplémentaires